blue for you is this MILF music thing a
real thing
I think I think we'll get more talent
coming in it's based off her
impression you know so in order to be on
your new label you have to have child
yeah you gotta have a kid like what's
the object for auditions Baby Daddy has
to be a reference like he asked about
truth so it doesn't have to be your baby
Mama's only on MILF music it could be
anybody who's got children yeah yeah
definitely can you be pregnant yeah yeah
what if someone's just expecting are you
pregnant you could be okay so that
qualifies
all we got to know is you got you got
something to lose you know you got
something to live for you got something
to die for you're not just like taking
advantage of the situation